bonjour je m'appelle fabian licka dans
ce format nous faisons un focus sur un
point particulier du cerveau dans les
épisodes précédents vous avez proposé
d'aborder notre capacité à changer ou à
nous adapter et c'est le sujet du jour
nouvelle mesure oblige je n'ai pas pu
reprendre les tournages de matière grise
j'ai donc créé ce nouveau format
keith alternera avec les épisodes
normaux bienvenue dans le mini matière
grise
[Musique]
pour qui
dans cet épisode nous allons vivre trois
expériences expérience une la myéline se
fait plaisir
expérience 2 c'est à vous expérience 3
adaptation immédiate de votre cerveau le
tout avec la présence ponctuelle très
apprécié de ses lignes
[Musique]
lorsqu'on essaie de changer quelque
chose dans notre vie dans notre manière
de penser ou tout simplement quand on
essaie de prendre une nouvelle habitude
notre cerveau ne nous aide pas bien au
contraire il aime ce qui connaît et
opposent une résistance farouche aux
changements certaines hypothèses
émettent l'idée que ce serait une sorte
de protection de notre système nerveux
le cerveau m la sécurité et la sécurité
c'est le confort de ce qu'il connaît
d'ailleurs votre cerveau et peut être
actuellement dérangé par le fait que la
boîte qui était tout à l'heure à
l'intérieur puisse maintenant contenir
la boîte qui était précédemment à
l'extérieur je vous expliquerai pourquoi
juste après l'expérience lune
laissez moi vous présenter la myéline
c'est une sorte de membrane qui vient
recouvrir les nerfs du cerveau et plus
précisément les circuits neuronaux
imaginez un peu une gaine en plastique
qui recouvrent un câble de fibres
internet
à la différence que plus on mettrait de
gaines en plastique et plus la vitesse
de connexion serait bonne quand vous
créez une nouvelle habitude qu'elle soit
dans l'action ou dans votre manière de
penser alors de la myéline va commencer
à se déposer sur ce nouveau circuit plus
il va y en avoir sur le neurone plus le
circuit sera efficace est donc naturel
sans souffrance là l'idée c'est que je
vais jouer à un jeu de logique et vous
allez pouvoir essayer de réfléchir en
même temps que moi ce qu'on va essayer
de générer ces de la myéline sur un
schéma de pensée particulier et du coup
d'adapter en même temps notre sens
logique ce qui fait que je vais devenir
de plus en plus rapide en théorie je
vais devenir meilleur au fur et à mesure
que je vais faire des parties dans ce
jeu angry sur la grille on va mettre des
choses qui ressemble à des voitures
selon ce schéma là et à chaque fois moi
le but du jeu c'est de pouvoir libérer
la voiture rouge en ne faisant que
glisser les choses je ne peux rien de
déplacé
je vais commencer par reproduire celui
ci
mon but est de sortir la voiture rouge
ici et donc j'ai juste seulement le
droit de déplacer dans le sens
évidemment des véhicules ça m'a l'air
très facile à banon ça a été trop facile
justement comme ça si je fais ça comme
ça d'accord et là ça doit pouvoir me
libérer
j'ai pu sortir la voiture rouge
en même temps on était sur un niveau
débutant mais c'était aussi pour que je
puisse comprendre les règles j'enchaîne
là je vais reproduire celui ci qui est
un niveau intermédiaire qui me paraît
quand même vachement plus complexe c'est
clairement c'est pas la même histoire
[Musique]
lui et on sort le rouge
ok celui ci était clairement plus dur on
a mis sept minutes ces cintres comme ça
ok je pense que j'ai vraiment galéré au
point de croire que j'avais fait une
erreur mais on va refaire un toujours en
intermédiaires donc là on veut aller ici
c'est à dire que lui d'une manière ou
d'une autre sur complètement décembre
[Musique]
la clac clac clac clac
là c'était un peu plus rapide je pense
qu'on a mis cinq minutes
donc on commence à s'améliorer dans la
logique et dans le schéma de pensée plus
j'ai joué à ce jeu est plus optimisée
mon chemin de pensée au départ je les
trouvais dur après je les trouvais
intéressant et à la fin j'ai commencé à
le trouver amusant et là j'ai juste
envie de résoudre encore en gros j'ai
optimiser ma manière de penser et de
visualiser pour résoudre ce problème là
précisément en conclusion plus nous
répétons un comportement ou une pensée
plus nous générons de myéline sur ce
circuit
au point que ça devienne une nouvelle
habitude mais attention le cerveau n'est
pas dans le jugement donc ça fonctionne
aussi bien pour les bonnes habitudes que
pour les mauvaises habitudes
cela rejoint une étude de philippe al
ahly en 2009 publiée dans le journal de
la psychologie sociale qui reléguait le
fameux 21 ou 30 jours pour changer au
rang des idées reçues cette étude menée
sur 96 personnes pendant 12 semaines a
démontré qu'il fallait en moyenne
évidemment 66 jours pour changer est
vraiment obtenir une nouvelle habitude
qui s'installe
c'est à dire qu'ils s'automatise sans
souffrance de manière naturelle
le temps évidemment de bien tout
recouvrir de myéline là-haut alors oui
au début ça peut être compliqué un petit
peu dur de changer de se réadapter parce
que notre cerveau est pas du tout prêt
pour ça mais à la fin ça peut être
bénéfique
un petit peu comme pour cette boîte
cette boîte qui donnait l'illusion
d'être complètement fermée au départ est
complètement car et on s'aperçoit qu'au
final elle ne l'est pas tant parce que
ici c'est bien de bord à bord ici c'est
bien fermé de bord à bord et pourtant
quand je rentre la première boîte dans
la deuxième on s'aperçoit que c'est
juste un petit peu différent
on va dire à quelques centimètres parce
qu'au final quand on change on ne perd
pas qui on est au départ on ne fait que
s'adapter que se modifier après
l'expérience de nous aurons
l'intervention d'une invitée que vous
connaissez bien qui nous racontera un
changement que son cerveau lui refuser
et qui pourtant lui a été plus que
bénéfique
[Musique]
le changement revient donc à perdre une
posture confortable du cerveau le
cerveau fera toujours son réac
ce qui fait que c'est compliqué de se
fier à son propre jugement pour se poser
la question est ce que c'est vraiment
utile pour moi et si oui pourquoi
le seul moyen de parasites et ça c'est
de se poser la question est ce que je
suis heureux ou simplement confortable
c'est ce que va nous expliquer tout à
l'heure notre invité juste après c'est à
vous nous allons maintenant faire un
test pour déterminer votre propre
résistance au changement alors notez
bien vos réponses question une quand
vous choisissez vos vêtements le matin
pour celles et ceux qui mettent des
vêtements le matin 1
vous prenez simplement les premiers qui
viennent 2 vous prenez ceux qui sont en
rapport avec votre journée mais qui sont
le plus pratique pour cette journée où 3
vous prenez ceux qui sont en rapport
avec votre journée mais qui sont les
plus esthétiques dans le dresscode idéal
de votre journée n'hésitez pas à faire
pause quelques secondes pour noter votre
réponse
question numéro 2 on vous propose des
vacances dans un pays que vous ne
connaissez pas mais que de prime abord
vous n'appréciez pas particulièrement un
vous refusez directement ça vous
intéresse pas 2 vous vous renseigner sur
les vaccins qu'ils auraient à faire pour
y aller ou 3 vous acceptez et vous
commencez à faire des recherches pour
voir ce qu'il ya à faire sur place
peut-être troisième question dans votre
rapport à l'écologie au climat à la
planète 1 vous avez toujours fait
attention à ça bien avant que ça
devienne un sujet de société un petit
peu à la mode
2 vous sentez un peu coupable quand vous
y pensez ou 3 vous suivez toujours les
consignes à partir du moment qu'elle
devienne obligatoire
quatrième question l'univers auquel vous
vous adaptez le mieux et un celui des
changements plutôt lifestyle la mode les
vêtements les soins et coupe de cheveux
ce genre de chose de celui du monde
le monde au sens de la société qui nous
entoure ou 3 celui de l'univers
technologique qui ne fait que changer en
permanence
question numéro 5 vous marcher
tranquillement dans la rue quand tout à
coup quelqu'un vous bouscule un vous
vous excusez directement de vous éclater
de rire ça vous fait marrer ou 3 vous le
regardez
en attendant de voir ses réactions prêts
à vous énerver si sa réaction ne vous
plaît pas je vous laisse faire vos
comptes selon vos propres résultats
voici un recap qui apparaît à l'écran on
va pouvoir en fonction de votre nombre
de points que d'être un petit peu votre
capacité à vous adapter aux changements
de 3 à 5
vous êtes en sueur adaptation c'est à
dire que vous courez vers la perfection
ce qui peut aussi vous empêcher d'être
en accord avec vos véritables valeurs et
vos vrais désirs
posez vous toujours la question de
pourquoi et pour qui vous voulez changer
vous adapter 2 - 2 à 2 vous êtes plutôt
un équilibre malgré une légère
résistance au changement lorsqu'il
chamboule trop votre confort de -3 à -5%
avait du mal à effectuer des changements
durables et cela peut parfois vous
provoquer un sentiment de culpabilité
vis-à-vis de vous même ou vis-à-vis des
autres commencer par opérer les
changements qui à court terme vous
rendront plus heureux vivons tous dans
une zone de confort qui comporte ses
propres frontières
à chaque fois qu'on veut faire un saut
dans l'inconnu parce qu'on veut changer
notre manière de faire ou de penser
c'est extrêmement déplaisant pour le
cerveau pourtant prendre une nouvelle
habitude va agrandir votre zone de
confort qui va à moyen terme absorber ce
qu'ils étaient avant l'inconnu vous
devez faire la différence entre la zone
de confort ce que vous maîtrisez et qui
vous laisse dans une situation
confortable
la zone d'apprentissage c'est un petit
peu comme quand on a un pied à
l'intérieur de la zone de confort et un
pied à l'extérieur ya pas vraiment de
risque mais on découvre quand même
quelque chose
la zone de panique qui est le vrai saut
dans l'inconnu c'est là où vous avez
donc la peur les angoisses la remise en
question et enfin la zone magique la
zone magique c'est quand la zone de
panique devient la zone de confort
c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé pour
notre invité céline h et du coup j'ai
demandé de venir nous faire un rapide
témoignages alors moi j'ai été très très
longtemps comédienne sur scène c'était
un objectif dans ma vie j'ai construit
articule
et toute ma vie en fonction de ça sur
paris parce que je voulais faire de la
scène j'ai réussi à me trouver une forme
de confort même une sécurité financière
et un jour est arrivé où j'ai commencé à
ressentir vraiment quelque chose de très
inconfortable je n'avais plus du tout
envie je traînais laprade je commence à
avoir des noeuds mais pourtant je
refusais l'idée de changer depuis mon
enfance depuis mon adolescence mon rêve
absolu c'était d'être sur scène et
j'étais dans mon rêve
une fois qu'on a réussi à avoir quand
même une forme de solidité on va pas
tout bascule et c'est déjà très
compliqué d'en vivre
j'ai pris la décision d'arrêter et
c'était horrible j'ai arrêté de faire de
la scène j'ai refusé les projets qu'on
proposé et j'ai décidé de monter une
chaîne youtube
je ne connaissais rien à internet je ne
savais pas monter des vidéos rien est-ce
que ça fait drôle mais c'est pas bon
mais c'est pas bien mais c'est pas assez
ou c'est trop soucis et aujourd'hui je
souris parce que quand je repense à ma
période où je me lançais où j'étais un
peu angoissé un peu paniqué en fait je
réalise à quel point ça a été bénéfique
parce que trois ans plus tard j'ai une
communauté qui a grandi qui m'a offert
plein d'autres opportunités
je maîtrise maintenant des choses que je
ne pensais pas pouvoir maîtriser j'écris
un roman je sors un deuxième est tous à
sa part de ce changement là que je
refusais que mon cerveau refusé qu'ils
ne pouvaient même pas concevoir
je m'aperçois que j'ai toujours gardé
les bénéfices de ce que j'ai pu vivre
expérimenté durant ma zone de confort
mais aujourd'hui je suis encore plus
riche de nouveaux savoirs de nouvelles
compétences
internet est devenu ma zone de confort
également et j'ai pas pour autant perdu
ben la zone de confort qui se situe au
niveau du spectacle donc j'ai juste
élargi ma zone de confort
dans cette troisième expérience vous
allez sentir votre cerveau changé en
temps réel il va devoir s'adapter à de
nouvelles données il est obligé de le
faire sinon il va se renfermer dans une
incompréhension frustrante
ce qui peut être très agréable par
exemple dans un tour de magie on verra
ça tout à l'heure mais pour le moment
patients à l'expérience
à la fin de la phrase un texte va
s'afficher à l'écran essayer de le lire
et vous allez constater que vous allez
le lire
de plus en plus rapidement
en temps normal vous venez de réussir à
décrypter ce texte qui paraît pourtant
incompréhensible pourquoi parce que les
lettres de chaque mot sont les vraies
lettres de ces mots là toutes les
lettres ont été mélangées à part la
première et la dernière de chaque mot ce
qui fait que votre cerveau peut
photographier une fois qu'il a compris
la mécanique
il s'adapte et il change il vous permet
de tout comprendre tenez vous prêts
voici un deuxième texte avec une méthode
légèrement différente essayer de les
lire le plus rapidement possible ça doit
être bon et comme tout à l'heure votre
cerveau s'est adaptée dès qu'il a
compris les nouvelles règles du jeu
ils s'adaptent très rapidement parce
qu'il ne veut pas rester frustré ce qui
nous prouve que le cerveau c'est changer
quand il le faut et nous allons conclure
cette expérience 3 avec l'expérience
mise au point par jeune gilles les
troupes en 1935 publiée dans le journal
of experimental psychologie vous voyez à
l'écran apparaître des mots colorés dans
un premier temps je vais vous demander
si possible à voix haute de lire le plus
rapidement possible tous les mots que
vous voyez
[Musique]
stop nous allons passer à la deuxième
étape de l'effet stroup maintenant vous
allez lire le plus rapidement possible
les couleurs des mots que vous voyez ci
jaune est écrit en rouge
vous devez dire rouge allez-y essayer de
le faire rapidement
[Musique]
plus compliqué n'est ce pas alors
simplement il ya une interférence de
votre automatismes dans le processus
cognitifs qui vous permet de traduire
une couleur que vous avez vu en un mot
que vous allez prononcer alors au final
quelles sont les clés du changement pour
que ce réactionnaire de cerveau puisse
adapter au plus vite en un il y a la
motivation c'est évidemment le fondement
de tout en deux il y a la régularité en
3 il ya le fait de faire des pauses de
s'économiser de prendre le temps de
prendre du repos en quatre pensez à
demander une seconde opinion à une
personne en qui vous avez confiance afin
de parasiter le côté du cerveau qui dit
c'était mieux avant je préfère avant ça
vous permettra d'avoir un jugement plus
lucides et enfin 5 sortait au maximum de
votre zone de confort pour habituer
votre cerveau à être régulièrement aux
zones d'apprentissage ce qui va reculer
un petit peu la zone de panique
maintenant avant le tour de magie je
vais vous parler du concept de il est
temps cette vidéo est réalisée en
collaboration avec arte qui m'a proposé
de participer à une expérience qui
s'appelle il est temps il est temps
c'est un questionnaire 232 questions
disponibles en lui lang qui a été mis en
ligne en europe et en asie le but
extrêmement ambitieux est de récolter
des dizaines de millions de réponses de
la part de tous les citoyens en
particulier des 16 34 ans sur la
question environnementale ce
questionnaire a pour but de lancer un
débat mondial s'est complètement humide
l'objectif ceci simplement de permettre
à tout à chacun de s'exprimer sur ce
sujet et de se positionner face aux
gigantesques défis à venir
les questions ont été écrites par les
sociologues du collectif quantité
critique et le questionnaire et
interactif par exemple qu'il y a des
vidéos à l'intérieur et les résultats
sont même parfois accessibles en temps
réel tout le monde peut participer et
s'exprimer je vous invite à le faire en
vous connectant à arte.tv slash
il tirait est tirée tant vous allez
pouvoir répondre à différents types de
questions parfois il ya des choix
parfois il n'y a pas de choix je vais
vous en dire quelques unes et je vais y
répondre mais aussi en temps réel comme
ça vous voyez simplement comment ça se
passe quelqu'un me dit l'écologie ça me
gonfle je suis d'accord avec cela
n'entre pas dans le débat
en discute je le ou la reille de ma vie
moi je pense à raison qu'on en discute
mon positionnement c'est d'en discuter
parce que en en discutant je vais aussi
mieux comprendre mon positionnement
personnel vis-à-vis de l'écologie c'est
intéressant une autre question c'est au
xxième siècle faire des enfants c'est
impossible
un cas de conscience oui quelles
questions et b pour être très honnête
pour moi c'est un cas de conscience
aujourd'hui j'ai voulu des enfants très
jeunes dans ma vie j'ai pas eu la
possibilité de concrétiser cette envie
là et aujourd'hui ça devient un vrai
questionnement pour moi c'est pas
forcément un avis tranché mais je ne
sais pas trop par rapport au futur j'ai
l'impression d'être responsable de ça
donc je dirais oui c'est un vrai cas de
conscience
question suivante j'apprends que ma
banque investit dans les énergies
fossiles
tant mieux c'est bon pour moi trop la
flemme de changer ou je choisis une
banque plus éthiques
ok il n'y a pas de réponse qui me
convient celle qui s'en approche le plus
si je veux vraiment honnête transparent
avec vous c'est trop la flemme de
changer j'ai c'est ça qu'il faut en fait
c'est que moi je suis sensibilisé à
l'écologie j'essaie de parler de ça de
véhiculer des messages de parler des
bonnes actions qui sont faites de
m'améliorer dans mon quotidien
mais on voit déjà à moi à quel point je
suis un parfait vis-à-vis de ça c'est
clair que déjà je ne sais pas où est ce
qu'elle investit ma banque je j'avoue je
m'y intéresse assez peu et si vraiment
j'étais en désaccord
est ce que ce serait suffisant pour
déclencher ce fameux changement de ce
cerveau réac qui me ferait entamé les
démarches d'un changement de banque qui
me paraît aujourd'hui hyper relou à
fermer parce que c'est de l'inconnu
j'ai jamais changé de banque de ma vie
donc en fait forcément que mon cerveau
est en train de refuser parce que ça lui
est inconfortable alors que si ça se
trouve c'est hyper facile à faire en
tout cas j'imagine que ça doit être
faisable et je même en train de me dire
ça de bien servir les banques en fait de
choper le client le plus tôt dans sa vie
tellement ça doit être assez peu
fréquent le changement de monde
vie ben voilà vous êtes en train
d'assister exactement à ce que génère ce
questionnaire même temps que de donner
mon avis je comprend des choses et je
trouve ça hyper intéressant on voit les
limites de ma zone de confort c'est
peut-être le moment on pour l illustrer
en magie on va symboliser la zone de
confort avec ses trois cartes là on a un
cadre de pique un deuxième est une dame
de coeur en fait on pourrait se dire
simplement que la vie c'est un bonne tôt
comme ça ou où tout se mélange en
permanence et si la dame de coeur c'est
notre habitude est bien de l'habitude
elle est bien ancrée quelque part et le
fait de vouloir la faire passer ailleurs
ça nous fait visiter une zone de panique
et c'est assez compliqué c'est comme la
même angoisse
du moins ça y ressemble de ne pas savoir
si les cartes sont vraiment là où elles
pensent qu'elles sont et pourtant à
force d'apprentissage la zone de confort
c'est dargis et la zone de panique
devient la zone magique alors pouvons
nous changer les schémas de notre
cerveau sommes nous condamnés à faire
rétrécir notre zone de confort
existe-t-il des déclencheurs puissant
pour notre pensée comment prenons nous
nos décisions nous verrons tout cela et
bien plus dans les prochains épisodes
mini matière grise
à très bientôt ciao